let's talk about net neutrality I've
been covering not only the federal
government effort to restore net
neutrality the Senate vote to do it
which now goes to the house but also
some of the state-level
efforts that have been going on and one
of those state-level efforts is in
California which is a state bigger than
many countries when it comes to
population and also GDP the California
or I guess it wouldn't be GDP it would
be state production state productivity
and the California Senate yesterday
voted to approve a bill that would
restore the net neutrality provisions
that were repealed by the FCC in
December it was approved completely
among Senate party lines 23 Democrats
all voted for net neutrality in
California 12 Republicans did not and
now it goes to the state assembly and
I'm hopeful that if the right wants to
live by states rights they might also
die by states rights and what I mean by
that is the FCC repeals net neutrality
federally 20 attorneys general sue at
the state level governor's look at using
executive orders to reinstate elements
of net neutrality and others look at
using their state Senate and
legislatures to maybe put net neutrality
back in and the same could apply in
other areas right like gun safety as
long as you don't violate the Second
Amendment states can do more than the
federal government is doing on gun
safety business regulation minimum wage
basic income test whatever else states
can do these things but of course only
some states can afford to usually blue
states that are better off economically
often subsidizing red states around the
country actually so back to net
neutrality in California this bill would
not only put back in place those
original net neutrality rules from 2015
under Barack Obama it would actually do
more and one of the things that the
California bill would do is block what
are called zero ratings zero rating
programs and what zero rating programs
are are when is piece a certain content
could be content they get money from
could be content they maybe even own
watching certain content doesn't count
towards your monthly data cap and that
is yet another way that an ISP can favor
some cons
and over other content and if the bill
ultimately passes Internet service
providers will not be able to get
government contracts in California
without sticking to the rules that are
passed and this is a really important
thing to understand states can't enforce
net neutrality directly as of right now
relates to commerce law there is a
lawsuit over that but as of right now
states can't just generally enforce net
neutrality law what states can do is to
set rules for what ISPs that they work
with have to do and this relates to
something called the market participant
doctrine we don't have to get into the
details of that but the way that states
can sort of effectively enforce net
neutrality is by setting requirements
that ISPs have to meet in order to get
contracts with the state what this sort
of means de-facto is that since an ISP
is not going to have one set of rules
for their state customers and another
set of rules for all other customers in
the state the state and individual
consumers basically just become
consumers and you've got the same rules
for everybody but what does it possibly
mean if the state laws start being
adopted in multiple states well that's
the idea right if you see multiple
states adopt laws that require some
version of net neutrality in order to
get state contracts you might see ISPs
just say you know what let's just make
this policy federally it is an uphill
battle it's a major one but it's one
that I think is worth fighting because
how important this issue is right I've
talked to you about the meta issue of
net neutrality and I'm going to keep you
posted about other states that are
working on similar bills right now
legislators in 29 states have introduced
more than 58 bills dealing with net
neutrality in some way shape or form
this is a good thing this is a meta
issue and it's an issue that whatever
activism you want to be doing whether
it's on LGBT rights or education or
whatever else your ability to be
effective in that activism will be
impacted by net neutrality and that is
why I am going to continue talking about
it discuss this with us on our subreddit
david pakman.com slash our EDD IT quick
Raik back after this today's episode of
the David Pakman show is made possible
in part by the master crypto currency
trader an online course created by
crypto 80 this is a fantastic new class
for anyone who's new to the world of
crypto currency and Bitcoin and maybe
you've heard about crypto currencies you
don't know much about it
you don't have any idea how to get
started this is the perfect way to do it
and the course was designed by veteran
crypto investor Chris Kony who has more
than ten years experience in currency
trading and he starts out teaching you
all the sort of core concepts in a way
that's really easy to absorb he lays out
a simple step-by-step system for making
smart decisions as a trader and by the
time you're done with the course you'll
have all the tools and knowledge you'll
need to get started in the world of
trading crypto currencies of course the
usual legal disclaimer I have to tell
you I'm not giving you financial advice
but I am telling you that the course is
definitely worth checking out you can
get 25% off by going to crypto versity
dot-com / Pakman and when you sign up
using that link you'll get two hundred
and fifty bucks worth of Bitcoin but
only if you go to crypto versity dot-com
/ Pakman and the first 50 people who
sign up will get this special deal
that's CR y PT o ve RS ity dot-com / PA
que ma n if you're watching this on
YouTube I've put a link underneath the
video